AND KLINGBERG IN THE ZONE.
TIPPED AWAY.RD
AND FRONT.
STEERED WIDE SHOT. THE PUCK ON
BOARDS AND LOOOO WAY.
BACKLUND SHOOTS.
PAD SAVE OETTINGER.
ANDEDE Applause ]R OVER THE PADE
CALGARY FLAMES AND THIS PLACE IS
GOING CRAZY AS T DOWN THE WING.
SHOT.
BOARDS.
TO KEEP
MOMENTUM.
SHOTS 9-0ENING.
AND THE PUCK CALGARY
DOES.
IN A REAL HURRY YOU HAVE TO GET.
PAST THE 12 MINUTE MARK OF THE
OPENING PERIOD. TANEV WIDE.
HINTZ PLAYS IT AROUND.
JASON ROBERTSON STICK LIFTED.
PUCK PLAYED TO THE BLUE LINE.
KEPT SIMU ULIS GREAT TO BE
LOOKING AT THE OTHER SIDE.
>>>> AROUND.
FIND NOAH HANIFIN IN THE CORNER.
FEEDS IT YEAR
STICK.
BUT TOUGH ANGLE TO GET THE SHO K
IN. IN.
OETTINGER WILL LEAVE IT BEHIND
THE NET FOR SUTER. DEFENCEMAN.
>> Rick: BACKLUND FACING
RAANTA BACK TO HANLEY.
WRISTS IT IN DEEP.
BIG BOUN
>> Rick: YUP.
LITTLE EASIER AT HOME WITH L L .
CHECKED TIMER ANDNDCheering and]
>> Greg: MARKSTROM NOT A LOT
OF WORK.
YOU HAV THE NET.
HANIFIN ABLE TO CHIP IT AHEAD TO
TOFFOLI.
LEANED IN FRONT.
>> Greg: SUTER GETS WIN.
HANIFIN WITH THE PUCK.
OR IT.
>> Rick: DON'T WANT TO GET
CHANGE LEFT.
>> Rick: ONE FOR FREE ON THE
ATTACK.
OUT.
KYLINGTON DOWN.
AND PENALTY TO DALLAS.
KYLINGTON TRIPPED.
WAY AROUND FS
TANEV WAITING
GET SET UP NOW.
TWO MAN ADVANTAGE.
GAUDREAU TO TKACHUK.
BACK TO
MIGHT BE A HIGH STICKING.
>> Greg: I THINK KNOCKING DOWN
WITH HIGH STICK.
THEY WILL A 1-0 GAME IN CALGARY.
THE SERIES OPENER BETWEEN THESE
TWO
PAVELSKI, ROBERTSON, ANDOO FAR.
THAT WILL BE
COMFORTABLE MOST NIGHTS.
>> Rick: SET TO GO AROUND.
RITCHIE FAR SIDE.
GOOD IN NET FOR
THE DALLAS STARS IN THE FIRST
PLAYOFF GAMETH LINE.
ACROSS TO LINDHOLM.
MISSED THE PASS.
PUCK C C
BACKLUND FALLS..